ich habe letztens für einen euro einen
gesamten tag über gekocht und heute gehe
ich für 100 euro ein abendessen das
heißt es muss sich wirklich lohnen weil
das ist das hundertfache von dem was wir
an dem tag ausgegeben haben und es ist
nur ein das besondere daran ist dass es
ein reines überraschungsmenü ist den
tipp habe ich bekommen vom restaurant
kritiker und vom sternekoch niemand geht
hin
es könnte sich lohnen das machen wir
heute und ich bin gespannt was uns
erwartet ich habe logischerweise
überhaupt keine ahnung so wissen jetzt
angekommen ihr erinnert euch vielleicht
waren ja schon mal hier geht einfach
wunderschön aus und ich feiere jetzt
schon so den gedanken gar nicht zu
wissen was auf uns zukommt als wir
angekommen sind haben wir erstmal einen
wunderschönen platz bekommen wir waren
auf dem hinweg dachten wir uns post ist
so ein schönes wetter wenn wir jetzt
draußen sitzen wenn wir kamen an und wir
saßen draußen also erstmal ein absoluter
traum weniger wasser drauf ist und
ich muss wirklich sagen das ist auch
sehr schönes restaurant bei dem sie
dabei als vidal auf unseren
wunderschönen platz schaffen haben wir
uns erstmals feier des tages ein abhol
sprits reingewinn und das war wirklich
eine sehr sehr gute stimme um sie wurde
noch besser als der erste gruß aus der
küche kam nämlich ein cast knödel auf
einem wurzelgemüse und ihr merkt schon
wir sind in einem österreichischen
restaurants ich dachte mir erstmal so
wie passt das so feine küche
österreichische küche weil ich überhaupt
keine berührungspunkte damit werde ein
kleines einmachglas obendrauf einen cast
press knödel dazu hat mir ein
wurzelgemüse muss und ich muss wirklich
sagen dass war ab dem ersten moment und
die pure vollmundigkeit
wie beschreibt man das ultra lecker
mit mir aber wirklich also wahnsinnig
lecker das ist so also diese
zufriedenstellung jemand kennt von
österreichischer küche so herzhaftes
deftiges essen aber mit so viel
raffinesse und das ist der appetizer
also das macht ganz viel spaß aber erst
mal kann man kleine boot variationen
drei verschiedene sorten oder dazu was
noch nicht kannte so ein kürbiskerne war
alles super lecker aber so weit so
normal was dann kam habe ich schon ein
bisschen mehr überrascht wir haben so
ein kleines reagenzglas bekommen darin
war ein herzhafter käse kuchen mit so
ein bisschen hier ein bisschen da ein
fachmann hatte für häufig das anschauen
noch drum herum ist und muss oder was
auch immer alles war super lecker der
war lauwarm und ich sage ehrlich habe
ich so noch nie gegessen aber fand ich
zehn von zehn so hast trotzdem über den
richtigen kick um hast du diesen wie
keks boden aber trotzdem kommt nicht
diese süße note wenn du bleibst ganz im
herzhaften als nächstes eine wirklich
wunderschöne kreation wir haben bisher
alles einfach nur so leckere einfach
lecker und im prinzip war das was wir
hatten einfach nur ein sehr sehr sehr
extravagante sandwich wertend effekt an
geröstetes butterbrot inzwischen hatten
wir da oben drauf eine creme eine kleine
haube von trüffel mario mit trüffel
raspelt also wirklich unnormal egger
jeder wirklich jeder würde das hier
mögen ja wohl trat schon fast ein
bisschen fruchtig das dart finish die
truppe mayonnaise
nächsten stufe mögliche endstufe dieses
cremiger eigelb ich kann mich nicht viel
sagen wollte
mir fehlen so ein bisschen die worte es
ist einfach nur ein traum
es ist alles bis jetzt zehn von zehn
motto ich muss wirklich sagen das war
alles ein absoluter traum ganz anders
als wenn man etwas auf raten kauft und
dann feststellt dass man verdammt hohe
zinsen zahlen muss aber da kommt er
nicht ins spiel das ding ist 47 prozent
aller deutschen nehmen einen kredit auf
und ich dinge leisten zu können so weit
so normal und bei jedem raten kaufen
immer an einen kredit auf der aber in
den meisten fällen viel zu hoch verzinst
ist ähnlich finns mission ist nämlich
den finanzmarkt fairer zu gestalten wenn
du also zu beraten scan deine ratenkauf
rechnung und annie film überprüft ob sie
die ein besseres angebot machen können
du bekommst wirklich nur dann ein
gegenangebot wenn es feststellt dass sie
die bessere konditionen bieten können
und das kannst du einfach eine app
überprüfen die super easy zu bedienen
ist wenn du das angebot dann an gehen
möchtest kannst du das super easy in der
app tun eine offene rechnung mit
abgezahlt du wirst kunde bei ähnlich
viel zahlt weniger zinsen und bist
schneller schuldenfrei das ganze ist
vollkommen kostenfrei mit dem code max
kriegst du 20 euro abzug auf deinen
refinanzierten kredit und ich verstehe
dass finanzprodukte vielleicht ein
bisschen undurchsichtig wirken aber ich
habe extra bei ähnlichem nachgefragt
warum macht das für euch sehen warum
macht das für den kunden sehen und die
antwort ist ganz einfach so seid ihr
fallen raus und andy film profitiert
davon dass ihr die zähne nicht mehr an
die bisherige wand seid das heißt es
kostenlos du hast nichts zu verlieren
ist es schnell und unkompliziert also
kurz auf den ersten ligen der video
beschreibung liegt ihr die app herunter
vielen lieben dank an die fans für die
unterstützung dieses videos und weiter
mit dem 100 euro überraschend die hat
das macht
auch falls spanien ball los wir haben
mit perlen dazu und ein grammys und
auch wenn es nicht glaubt da schon so
ein leichtes sättigungsgefühl ersetzt
und unserem ehren wir uns gefreut als es
leicht weiter ging immerhin pochiertem
wachtelei bekommen und dazu so ein paar
apfel und was ich wirklich auch sehr
interessant fand etwas angegossen mit
einem apfel so hatten wir wirklich was
leicht dass frisches und was soll ich
sagen das muss man sich auch meinen
hinterkopf rufen sie sind ja ein
restaurant das keinen michelin stern hat
von der präsentation es hält das absolut
schritt finde ich mit dem sterne
restaurants in den wir bisher kannten
nicht nur mit den einen auch mit den
zwei stellen und genau hier absolut
überraschungsmenü trifft bei diesem gang
nicht so wenig wussten was kommt sondern
weil man auch durch den geschmack
überrascht wird so macht einfach spaß so
ein schönes essen können sie auf jeden
fall deswegen auch weiter beim nächsten
gang wir hatten eine wolke aus schaum
innen drin ein perfekt gedämpftes stücks
kreis obendrauf rhabarber schnitzer also
auch mal wieder ärger und ich dachte es
auch sowie essen schon wie das
kreiseigene irgendwas nochmal noch so an
unserem job es war schon fast eigentlich
mehr ein kunstwerk was sich da auf dem
teller geboten hat es war aber
geschmacklich trotzdem super gut aber
wieder ein bisschen zurückgehalten und
unsere gebete wurden erhört wir haben
einen gebackenen schweinebauch bekommen
und den konnten wir jetzt wirklich
wieder richtig wertschätzen weil wir
hatten zwei leichte sagt unsere
geschmacksknospen durften sich ein
bisschen ausruhen und dann kam dieser
schweine braucht er war wirklich
gebacken also nicht auf einer seite
angebrachten sondern und rundum knusprig
innen drin trotzdem noch so fasst
flüssig also ultra saftig einfach auch
mega spaß gemacht ihn zu essen ich
kannte das auch überhaupt nicht dazu
eine zwiebel marmelade und einfach human
auf einem teller ich erwarte wirklich
sehr viel so das ist ein super fertiges
stück fleisch
ich habe mich noch nie fleisch mit so
einer textur gegessen denn er sowieso
diesel sowie sowieso puffreis schon
platz die die kruste auf dieser
schweinebauch
das kenne ich so einfach noch nicht
kennen diese zubereitungsart kenne ich
einfach nicht und dies so gut also
wirklich einfach nur perfekt die bohnen
diese firma milliarde auch wieder
eigentlich bekannte sachen aber trotzdem
dazu bereitung in einem zusammenspiel
wir uns noch nicht kennt ich muss aber
auch noch mal festhalten wir sind hier
in einem überraschungsmenü und ich weiß
ich bin wahrscheinlich ein willkommener
gast von überraschungs mit mir weil ich
nicht irgendwie in sachen überhaupt
nicht mag oder so aber bis dato bei
meinen geschmack zu 100 prozent
getroffen jedes mal und das ist schon
krass war schon zu finden wir hatten
eigentlich damit rechnen müssen wir sind
in einem gehobenen österreichischen
restaurants wir haben einen kleinen
happen wiener schnitzel bekommt aber
dieser kleine ab und hat es in sich sie
sind weit in wien und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob wir in wien ein so gutes
schnitzel essen werden erstmal
ordentlich zitrone drüber magst du dein
spitze mit viel oder wenig zu tun ich
mag das auto
ist aber absolut sicher das beste
schnitzel so die perfekt dünn geklopft
oberschale ascom vorzug auch hier so
nicht simples produkt eigentlich im
schnitt zelle wenn du gute rohstoff fast
unglaublich lecker zu diesem zeitpunkt
haben wir bestimmt schon wieder zwei
stunden im restaurant gesessen und erst
dann kam ja eigentlich ist alles schau
der haupt dazu haben wir uns weil wir
jetzt profis sind ein glas wein bestellt
und werde nicht amüsiert sage ich mal
denn sein erst mal ein bisschen luft
geben er geht vielmehr auf dem schönen
körper ein bisschen muskelkater
städte
bisschen mehr luft gehen wir sind schon
getrunken aber überhaupt den rhein
gepumpt wir können jetzt nicht so viel
daraus lesen wie maximilian lorenz
verbandkasten hemd aber es hat spaß
gemacht
zum gericht ich weiß gar nicht was ich
sagen sollte dieser pool aus einem
maximal intensiven braten schön
ermittelt dazu kalbsfilet ist noch nicht
gegessen habe es war wirklich kontos mit
der gabel ins herz ihn und in der mitte
ein würfel vom iberico viele getränkt in
diesem zweiten stufe als mann an der
seite noch diesen kleinen katze entdeckt
hat habe ich gesagt die leute glauben
uns nicht wenn wir jetzt sagen dass das
wieder so groß war wie es war mir das
ist kein der soße ist ein lack wirklich
das rad gesehen ihr wollt mit meiner
gabeln stück abgerissen ich muss das
nicht schneiden würde ich das auch so
kann es ja alles zusammen bauen ist ein
blumenkohl bisschen zwiebel war mir da
gewollt wird keine zehn um das sind es
ist wirklich so lecker das ist wieder so
eine reine pure um haben die explosion
was cool diesen gang war dass man wieder
so ein comeback hatte nicht nur von dem
casting sollen werden ob dieses zwiebel
chutney und weil wir uns hat alles
wieder zusammen gepasst ihr glaubt
wahrscheinlich nicht aber es ging sehr
gut weiter ein apfelstrudel das war
quasi die miniatur formen von einem
apfel strudel aber er war mindestens
genauso lecker wie ein xxl apfelstrudel
wir hatten dazu ein kleines haselnuss
als und auch das war wieder ein
österreichischer klassiker der perfekt
zubereitet war und das besondere ist bis
zu diesem zeitpunkt lediglich der
meinung würde das fast jedem schmecken
wir hatten wirklich schon besucher im
gehobenen restaurants hopmann gefühl
studiert haben muss um das zu verstehen
aber hier schmeckt es einfach
dann kam das bisher und plötzlich haben
wir gar nichts merken checkt also dann
kann es nicht anders sagen des azteken
gold war auch wieder bildhübschen hatte
wie eine pyramide aus tonkabohne keine
frage das war handwerklich wieder
perfekt und ich meine ihr seht ja diesen
teller dass er ist bildhübsch aber es
hat einfach in diesem gesamtkontext des
menüs nicht so viel sinn gemacht für
mich und hat mir ganz persönlich auch
einfach nicht so gut geschmeckt dann
wurde es auch zeit für das echte finale
das dritte bisher werten thymian makarov
wo ich mir dachte ob das gut schmeckt
was schmeckt unnormal gut dass diese
butter note mit dem thymian feierabend
und eine mozartkugel die wirklich
explodiert ist in deinen mund weil es
das gehört haben wir uns auch noch ein
bisschen kaiserschmarren gebracht der
ultra lecker war das ist wieder
vollkommen gelungen das einzige was in
diesem gesamtkonstrukt für mich keinen
sinn gemacht hat war dieses azteken gold
also der ingo wagner sage ich jetzt
einfach mal wenn ich den ausgegliederte
ist das für mich ultra heftig gewesen
die 100 euro
maximalwert ich habe ja eingangs das
beispiel genannt was ich selbst gekocht
habe für 1 euro und was felsen fest
steht wenn du selbst einkaufs kannst du
diese menü niemals für 100 euro kaum da
sind die feinsten zutaten drin und wenn
man ganz ehrlich ist wenn man den
brotkorb raus zählt wurde uns elfmal
essen gebracht 11 main das heißt unter
zehn euro für ein gericht dieser güte
und das ist schon wirklich wirklich
fährt muss ich echt sagen
ja es ist wahnsinnig gut es war ein sehr
sehr schöner restaurantbesuch und ja wie
gesagt halt ein klassischer dienstag